[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen Norbert Lehmann hat
heute alles Wichtige vom Fußball für Sie
als erstes schauen wir auf das Ringen um
den Klimaschutz
ein Schutzschirm gegen die Klimakrise
Kanzler Scholz will auf der
Klimakonferenz seine Pläne vorstellen
Kritikern reichen sie nicht
wie sehr wackelt das Bürgergeld die
Union will erstmal die Hartz-IV-Sätze
erhöhen und dann verhandeln
und haufenweise hammerlose alle vier
deutschen Teams haben im Achtelfinale
der Champions League harte Gegner
erwischt
[Applaus]
deutlicher kann eine Warnung nicht sein
wir sind auf dem Highway zur klima-hölle
mit dem Fuß auf dem Gaspedal so
UN-Generalsekretär uterisch heute vor
Staats- und regierungschefinnen und
Chefs bei der Weltklimakonferenz kanzer
Scholz wirbt dabei für seine Idee eines
globalen Schutzschirms zur Abfederung
von Klimaschäden Elisa Miebach berichtet
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz reist nicht
mit leerem Gepäck zur Klimakonferenz er
bringt einen Schutzschirm von 170
Millionen Euro mit ein Programm mit dem
Klimaschäden gerade in ärmeren Ländern
besser abgesichert werden sollen
ein Pakt mit dem reiche Länder und
internationale Finanzinstitutionen
finanzielle und technische Hilfe für
Entwicklungsländer geben
schaut man auf die historischen
Emissionen die die Länder seit Beginn
der industriellen Revolution ausgestoßen
haben liegt Deutschland auf dem fünften
Platz weltweit
die Stimmen der ärmsten Länder sind hier
auf der Konferenz laut sie hätten am
wenigsten zum Klimawandel beigetragen
müssten aber die Kosten der Schäden oft
allein tragen und auch der globale
Schutzschirm mit 170 Millionen Euro von
Scholz wird dieses Problem nicht lösen
insgesamt greift die Maßnahmen natürlich
zu kurz Klimaschäden sind viel viel
teurer wir erwarten hier Schadensummen
von 300 bis 600 Milliarden Euro ab dem
Jahr 2030 in Entwicklungsländern alleine
das heißt diese Initiative sehr
willkommen muss aber auch noch ausgebaut
werden und andere Industriestaaten
müssen als Mitstreiter gewonnen werden
ein weiterer Kritikpunkt der globale
Schutzschirm könne zwar Schäden von
Naturkatastrophen direkt absichern die
langsamen und schleichenden Auswirkungen
des Klimawandels wie etwa das Schmelzen
von Gletschern Wüstenbildung oder das
versalzen von Flüssen können nicht durch
eine Versicherung abgefedert werden die
eigentlichen Verhandlungen zur
Finanzierung von Klimaschäden gehen nach
Ausrede hier jetzt erst richtig los
und vor Ort in Sharm el Sheikh ist für
uns auch schakunta la benedy chakantala
auch auf Deutschland steigt der Druck
mehr zu tun gegen die Klimakrise mit
welchen Zusagen ist Kanzler Scholz nach
Ägypten gekommen
ja noch warten wir auf die Rede von Olaf
Scholz die hätte vor anderthalb Stunden
schon stattfinden sollen aber hier
verschiebt sich alles so oder
einigermaßen weil doch alle sehr viel zu
sagen haben und wir warten in den
nächsten Minuten drauf bis dahin kann
man nicht ganz genau sagen was er im
Gepäck hat allerdings ist klar wie die
Erwartungshaltung hier ist es geht um
Geld es geht auch um den globalen
Schutzschirm eine Art klimaversicherung
für die besonders betroffenen Länder die
im unter Klima vollgeschäden leiden und
da hat die Bundesregierung in der sieben
Präsidentschaft in den letzten Monaten
relativ viel vorangetrieben und auch
zuvor vor dieser Konferenz hier gesagt
das möchte sie weiter tun da ist jetzt
die Frage wird Olaf Scholz hier noch ein
konkretes Zeichen setzen Deutschland
könnte sich zum Beispiel an einer
Anschubfinanzierung für eine solche
Versicherung beteiligen wird das
passieren das werden wir hier hören vier
Minuten Zeit hat Olaf Scholz für seine
Rede da warten jetzt alle ganz gespannt
drauf und auch auf die Frage welche
anderen Zusagen es möglicherweise noch
gibt Dankeschön sie werden das weiter
für uns beobachten schokotella venegy
nach Deutschland am 1 Januar so der Plan
der Ampelkoalition soll das Bürgergeld
kommen und Hartz IV ablösen die Union
hält aber auch nach einem
Kompromissvorschlag weiter nicht viel
von dem Gesetzentwurf und droht das
Bürgergeld im Bundesrat zu blockieren
ein Vorwurf der Union durch das
Bürgergeld würde man mehr Geld bekommen
als wenn man für den Mindestlohn
arbeitet ist das so Christoph destarell
mit einem Faktencheck
zum Beispiel ein Arbeitsloser Single ab
Januar würde er 502 Euro Bürgergeld pro
Monat bekommen also gut 50 Euro mehr als
bisher dazu das Geld für seine
brutto-kaltmiete und fürs Heizen bekäme
damit ungerecht viel vielleicht sogar
mehr als die rund 6 Millionen Deutschen
die für Mindestlohn Vollzeit arbeiten
ein Beispiel zum Vergleich ein
arbeitender Single kommt bei Mindestlohn
auf rund 1.500 Euro netto muss davon
aber Miete und Heizung selbst bezahlen
und könnte so tatsächlich schlechter
dastehen als mit Bürgergeld außer er
stockt auf etwa über Wohngeld oder
Freibeträge so hätte er zwar mehr als
mit Bürgergeld müsste dafür beanträge
stellen doch das machen nicht alle
Betroffenen zu kompliziert für manche
vielleicht auch zu beschämend
meist ist der Vergleich Mindestlohn
Bürgergeld aber noch viel komplizierter
verheiratet alleinerziehend Kinder
Besitz jede Lebenslage eine andere
Berechnung und doch zeichnet sich ab
dass Mindestlohn und Bürgergeld manchmal
kritisch nah beieinander liegen könnten
wobei ein Unterschied bliebe nur wer
arbeitet zahlt auch für seine spätere
Rente ein
am Donnerstag soll im Bundestag über das
Bürgergeld abgestimmt werden die Union
hat erklärt lediglich dafür zu stimmen
dass die Regelsätze für Hartz IV erhöht
werden über die politische Debatte
berichtet Lars
wochenlang hieß es bei der Union dass
bei der geplanten Anhebung des
Bürgergeldes um 53 Euro der Lohnabstand
zu Geringverdiener nicht mehr groß genug
sei und damit der Anreiz zu arbeiten im
Falle nun stimmt CDU-Chef Merz der
Erhöhung überraschend zu lehnt alle
anderen bürgergeldregelungen aber
weitgehend ab wir sind mit der Höhe der
Sätze einverstanden das werde ich morgen
jedenfalls vorschlagen und dann können
wir das in dieser Woche im Deutschen
Bundestag verbindlich so mit einem
Gesetz beschließen und dann müssen wir
uns allerdings über alle anderen Themen
dieses sogenannten Bürgergeldes
ausführlich unterhalten da gibt es viel
zu kritisieren der Arbeitsminister zeigt
sich überrascht eine abgetrennte
Entscheidung über die Höhe der
Regelsätze lehnt er jedenfalls ab das
Argument von einem März verwundert mich
ein bisschen in den letzten Tagen hat
die Union sich immer beklagt dass der
Lohnabstand nicht groß genug sei das ist
inzwischen wissenschaftlich auch
widerlegt jetzt wechselt sie den
Zusammenhang und will nur das Geld
erhöhen das wäre für
arbeitsmarktpolitisch zu kurz Ursprung
deshalb werden wir für eine große Reform
das ist hier nicht die Zeit mehr für
parteitaktische Spielchen von der
aktuell hohen Inflation sind vor allem
die Ärmsten betroffen die Linke warnt
Richtung Union die Gesellschaft zu
spalten wir werden diejenigen die wenig
haben in Stellung gebracht gegen
diejenigen die gar nichts haben dass der
völlig falsche Weg sollte die Union wie
angekündigt das Bürgergeld über den
Bundesrat blockieren müsste das Gesetz
in den Vermittlungsausschuss viel Zeit
bliebe dort nicht mehr und so scheint es
auf einmal möglich dass die Erhöhung des
Bürgergeldes im Januar doch noch nicht
kommt
und wir bleiben beim Thema Geld und der
Preis Bremse für Strom Gas und Fernwärme
83 Milliarden Euro plant Finanzminister
Lindner dafür im nächsten Jahr ein das
sind Ausgaben die über den 200
Milliarden Euro schweren vorgestimmt
werden der außerhalb des Haushalts läuft
mit dem Geld sollen bis 2024 die hohen
Energiepreise abgefedert werden
es ist ein Wunschbündnis weshalb war man
sich auch schnell einig rund einen Monat
nach der Landtagswahl in Niedersachsen
steht die rot-grüne Koalition SPD
Ministerpräsident weil und Grünen
Spitzenkandidat in Hamburg
unterzeichneten den Koalitionsvertrag am
Vormittag in Hannover am Wochenende
hatte die Basis beider Parteien
zugestimmt beide soll schon morgen als
Ministerpräsident bestätigt werden und
damit in seine dritte Amtszeit gehen
monatelang hatte Peter Feldmann in
Frankfurt am Main an seinem
oberbürgermeisterstuhl geklebt und
versucht diverse Skandale auszusitzen
sexistische Sprüche gegenüber
Flugbegleiterinnen oder der seltsame
Empfang der Eintracht Fußballer zählten
dazu vor allem aber ein laufendes
Korruptionsverfahren aber nun haben die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger von Frankfurt am
Main entschieden der SPD-Mann muss den
Römer schon an diesem Freitag Räumen an
der abfallbeteiligten sich mehr als
200.000 Frankfurter deutlich mehr als
nötig
Ukraine Krieg beschuldigen sich Kiew von
Moskau gegenseitig zivile Infrastruktur
zur zerstören in der von Russland
protulierten Großstadt Donezk wurde die
Zentrale der Eisenbahnverwaltung nach
Angaben der Behörden von ukrainischen
Raketen getroffen und schwer beschädigt
Präsident selenski war Russland
terroristische Attacken auf Hacke
saporisha und Kia vor viereinhalb
Millionen Menschen sein ohne Strom im
südlichen Hassan bleibt die Lage
angespannt ukrainische Truppen bereiten
sich darauf vor in Richtung des Flusses
in den USA steht morgen einiges auf dem
Spiel bei den mitturmwahlen wird sich
entscheiden ob Präsident beiden seine
politische Mehrheit behält oder ihm die
Republikaner im Kongress das Leben
schwerer machen können
besonders bei den Kopf von kopfrennen in
manchen Staaten werden die Duelle
erbittert ausgefochten beide Lager
versuchen mit Polarisierung ihre
Anhängerschaft zum mobilisieren kurz vor
dem Urnengang kämpfen Präsident beiden
und seinen Vorgänger Donald Trump noch
mal um Stimmen aus Washington MRT wissen
bis zum letzten Moment klopfen sie an
die Tür und werben noch um neu Wähler
für die Demokratische Partei der die
Umfragen stehen nicht gut der Präsident
muss sogar im traditionell Liberalen New
York noch für seine Parteifreundin
Cassie hawkull Trommeln weil ihre
Wiederwahl als Gouverneurin knapp werden
könnte trumpistische Republikaner seien
eine Gefahr für die Demokratie
das Gerede von wahllügen Menschen
einschüchtern weiter Spalten alles was
wir als Demokraten zurückweisen
in meiner Karriere habe ich noch nie
erlebt dass Gewalt aus politischen
Gründen gerechtfertigt wird
aber wichtiger als die Angst um die
Demokratie ist den Amerikanern das Thema
Wirtschaft viele geben den Präsidenten
eine Mitschuld an den Preissteigerungen
schon jetzt zeichnet sich eine
rekord-wahlbeteiligung ab in manchen
republikanisch geprägten Orten sind
bewaffnete deputes an den
wahlbriefkästen postiert angeblich um
Wahlbetrug zu verhindern
in den knappen Rennen wollen sich viele
Republikaner nicht festlegen ob sie eine
Wahlniederlage akzeptieren würden ich
hoffe dass ich das kann aber ich weiß
nicht was die Demokraten vorhast
auch er macht weiter Stimmung seit
Zweifel an der Verlässlichkeit der Wahl
und komplettiert mit einem möglichen
Comeback
um unser Land erfolgreich sicher und
glorreich zu machen muss ich vermutlich
wiederkommen
bleibt dran
landesweit gibt es rund 300
Kandidatinnen die die Lüge von der
angeblich gestohlenen
Präsidentschaftswahl weiter verbreiten
als künftige Parlamentarier Gouverneure
innen und Justizminister könnten sie
Donald Trump falls er wieder antritt
2024 auch bei einer Niederlage wieder
ins Amt verhelfen auch Russland befeuert
nach Recherchen der New York Times die
Polarisierung bei den US-Wahlen Putin
Berater Jewgeni pregorian bestätigte
jetzt die Einflussnahme all das keine
guten Nachrichten für Amerikas
Demokratie
für veganen Moskau wie ist denn dieses
Eingeständnis von prigoshi in
einzuordnen das Russland sich in die
US-Wahlen eingemischt habe
ja Jewgeni war bisher eigentlich jemand
dessen gute Beziehungen zu Kremlchef
Putin zwar bekannt waren der seine
Geschäfte aber ganz diskret abgewickelt
hat das hat sich verändert mit dem
Russlands Einmarsch in die Ukraine denn
dort kämpft auch pregorians
wagner-gruppe eine Söldnertruppe die für
ihre Brutalität und Effizienz berüchtigt
ist deren Existenz Präsident Putin aber
immer abgestritten hat jetzt hat im
September briochien zugegeben das was
alle schon lange eigentlich wussten
nämlich dass er der Chef dieser
wagnergruppe ist und heute hat er also
einen weiteren Schritt in die
Öffentlichkeit gemacht und er wird sich
davon versprochen haben die Zweifel
weiter zu befeuern am Wahlausgang in den
USA ganz egal wie genau dort dem die
demokratischen Regeln eingehalten werden
damit wiederum unterstützt er dann das
was immer wieder Moskaus Ziel zu sein
scheint nämlich die Aushöhlung von
demokratischen Institutionen in Amerika
in Europa aber auch in Deutschland und
Pädagogin der positioniert sich hier
also immer weiter als Macher zum einen
auf dem in der Ukraine und zum anderen
im hybridenkampf gegen westliche
Demokratien danke für diese Einordnung
für Becker
und zurück nach Deutschland und zu einem
Meilenstein für alle Beschäftigten in
Deutschland das
Betriebsverfassungsgesetz wird in diesem
Monat 70 Jahre alt Anfang der 50er Jahre
hatten die Gewerkschaften das Gesetz
erkämpft es legt die Grundlage für die
betriebliche Mitbestimmung beim Festakt
heute morgen in Berlin war Kanzler
Scholz dafür das Gesetz
weiterzuentwickeln und die Betriebsräte
zu stärken eine Transformation der
Wirtschaft können nur gelingen wenn
Arbeitnehmer mitredeten sagte Scholz
jedem fünften Kind zwischen einem und
acht Jahren wird nie von den Eltern
vorgelesen so der vorlesemonitor
weiteren fast 20% der Kinder wird nur
einmal pro Woche oder seltener
vorgelesen vor allem Eltern mit einem
geringen Bildungsabschluss lesen laut
Studie seltener vor wenn die Eltern
nicht vorlesen dann starten die Kinder
mit deutlich schlechteren
Bildungsvoraussetzungen in die Kitas und
in die Schulen so Jörg Maas
Hauptgeschäftsführer der Stiftung Lesen
über die Klima und die Energiekrise
haben wir am Anfang der Sendung schon
berichtet die Folgen von beiden sind
auch in den Skigebieten zu spüren
vergleichsweise hohe Temperaturen und
hohe Energiekosten das alles macht das
Skifahren dieses Jahr noch teurer das
bekommen die knapp 15 Millionen Ski- und
snowboardfahrerinnen und Fahrer in
Deutschland zu spüren die müssen sich
auf satte Preiserhöhungen einstellen in
den Skigebieten wird aber auch nach
Lösungen gesucht Energie und damit
Kosten einzusparen etwa durch weniger
Kunstschnee Claudia Vogelmann berichtet
der erste Schnee liegt schon in den
Alpen auch auf der Zugspitze doch
erreicht bei weitem noch nicht aus für
den Skibetrieb im Tal sind die Pisten
noch grün sicher ist auch in diesem
Winter wird im Skigebiet Garmisch
classic beschneit werden Energiekrise
hin oder her für die Umweltorganisation
Greenpeace ist die Beschneiung
indiskutabel wir müssen uns einfach
darauf einstellen dass auch im Alpenland
weniger Schnee fallen wird in den
kommenden Jahren und da jetzt
gegenzuarbeiten mit Schneekanonen die
gleichzeitig auch noch eine Unmenge an
Wasser und energieverbrauchen und damit
den Klimawandel ja noch weiter anheizen
das ist absolut unverantwortlich die
Betreiber der Zugspitzbahn gehen in die
Offensive künftig wollen Sie mehr grünen
Strom einsetzen
wir haben Solaranlagen wir wollen das
Thema Wasserkraft bei der vorantreiben
wird eben auch dazu führen dass wir
letztendlich da auch CO2-neutraler
werden nur mit Kunstschnee beginnt die
alpine Skisaison dann wann sie soll
unmittelbar vor den Weihnachtsferien
doch Schneekanonen sollen nicht mehr
flächendeckende eingesetzt werden die
Pisten sollen schmäler die schneedecker
dünner ausfallen der Betrieb der
Bergbahnen und Skilifte macht 40% des
gesamten Energiebedarfs aus hier sollen
Kosten reduziert werden die Sitzheizung
der Sessellift der etwa bleibt aus Lift
dir und Seilbahnen fahren langsamer in
Randzeiten weniger Komfort bei
steigenden Preisen 57 Euro wird ein
Skipass in dieser Saison Kosten das soll
sich für Garmisch rechnen jeder Euro der
bei uns umgesetzt wird hat den Faktor 5
noch mal in der Region ganz klar
Hotellerie hängt bei uns sind die
Restaurants die gesamte Tourismus
eigentlich mit
trotz hoher Energiekosten hoffen die
Seilbahnbetreiber auf eine gute
Wintersaison
und nun zu den achtelfinalspielen in der
Champions League Norbert das war
wirklich eine hammer Auslosung absolut
schlimmer geht's nimmer könnte man fast
aus der Sicht der vier deutschen Vereine
sagen Leipzig muss gegen Manchester City
ran Frankfurt gegen Neapel Dortmund
gegen Chelsea ja und die Bayern diesmal
ohne Losglück
Paris Saint-Germain die Prominenten Elf
aus Paris also Frankreichs Meister
nächster Prüfstein für Bayern ein
rasantes Spiel zu erwarten gegen Messi
Neymar Map und Kollegen der Bayern
Trainer trotzdem entspannt aus dem Tag
vergegner klar die für die Weltklasse
Spiele haben gleich gilt für uns
Champions League halt so ist es Freude
und leichtes erschrecken in Sachsen
Irland Holland und Manchester City die
derzeit vielleicht beste Clubmannschaft
der Welt trifft auf Leipzig in Dortmund
dagegen freuen Sie sich auf Chelsea
unter anderem Deutschlands WM-Fahrer Kai
havertz prüft dann im neuen Jahr die BVB
Defensive das vierte deutsche Team die
Hessen aus Frankfurt zieht es nach
Neapel Tradition pur in Italien auf die
Eintracht deine März auf Jubel szenen
wie diese
[Applaus]
ja und attraktive Gegner auch in der
Zwischenrunde der Europa League für die
beiden deutschen Vereine Bayer
Leverkusen trifft auf AS Monaco und
Union Berlin auf den niederländischen
Meister Ajax Amsterdam zur
Fußball-Bundesliga da hat gestern abend
Freiburg gegen Köln 2:0 gewonnen die
Breisgauer jetzt hinter den Bayern
tabellenzweiter
Christian Streich und seine Freiburger
jagen die Bayern da kann man schon mal
emotional werden nur einen Punkt stehen
sie in der Tabelle hinter den Münchnern
was einem furiosen Spiel und vor allem
einem kaltschnäuzigen Michael
Gregoritsch zu verdanken ist denn der 53
Minute Jürgen schickt der Südkoreaner
trifft zum eins zu null und dann nach
Flanke von Kapitän Günther macht's
Gregoritsch selbst 64 minute völlig frei
und mit Köpfchen der Freiburger
Höhenflug geht weiter in der Europa
League schon im Achtelfinale kämpfen sie
sich in der Liga an Union vorbei auf
Platz 2 und uns alle Tore und alle
Höhepunkte des 13 Spieltags bei uns
zusammengefasst und zu sehen bei
heute.de und in der heute App
November nicht grau bleibt es morgen
hier und da die Temperaturen allerdings
sind wieder deutlich zu mild für die
Jahreszeit mehr zum Wetter hat gleich
Katja horneffer für sie eine gelinek
begrüßt sie um 21.45 zum heute-journal
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend wenn Ihnen das am Wochenende
schon etwas zu kühl war jetzt wird es
schon wieder milder denn die Wolken
kommen von Westen von Südwesten heran
sie bringen etwas Regen mit und mit
etwas Regen haben wir es auch in der
Nacht zu tun zumindest in
Schleswig-Holstein und auch hier im
westlichen Niedersachsen sonst gibt es
mal mehr mal weniger starke bewölkerung
und südlich der Donau es ist zum Teil
auch klar dann bildet sich Nebel zum
Teil mit geringen Sichtweisen denn
südlich der donauwörts kalt da sinken
die Temperaturen auf plus drei bis minus
ein Grad da droht also nicht nur
Bodenfrost sondern auch Luft Frost Frost
in zwei Meter Höhe sonst sinken die
Temperaturen auf 11 bis 4 Grad und
morgen gibt es am Oberrhein dann
vielleicht sogar noch mal an die 20 Grad
sonst liegen die Temperaturen bei 13 bis
17 Grad wenn sich der Nebel hält länger
hält dann bleibt es auch kälter denn der
Nebel wird am Vormittag hier recht zähl
sein im Donautal viel Sonne gibt es
dagegen im Nordosten von Westen werden
die Wolken dann am Nachmittag immer
dichter zu nächsten das so hohe
Schleierwolken bis dann der richtigen
einsetzt wird die Sonne wohl
untergegangen sein am Mittwoch
überqueren uns der neue Regenwolken
Gewitter sind an der Küste dabei danach
geht es relativ ruhig und etwas kühler
weiter bei 9 bis 15 Grad guten Abend